we're paying a visit to the Fraunhofer
Institute in Stuttgart to discover what
the city of tomorrow might look like and
this is the perfect place to find out
stefan brown works for the city of the
future which is a joint research project
at a number of fallen wolf institutes
scientists there are looking for ways to
make urban centers more livable and
sustainable and that means figuring out
how to make cities quieter cleaner and
more environmentally friendly
one possibility houses and buildings
could produce their own energy
it's much Cuba people building facades
could be equipped with their own power
stations which would then emit hydrogen
they'd have biocatalysts sunlight would
cause bacteria to produce hydrogen which
could be collected natural gas from
biological sources would be another
alternative that could be used to heat
the building or to generate energy
electricity and so forth
it's an idea with a lot of potential
rooftops could also be used differently
they could be turned into park-like
spaces or even used to grow crops that
can help reduce the need to transport
food over long distances there are
millions of square meters on rooftops
that are only used for heating or
air-conditioning units but these
rooftops could also be a way to bring
farming into the city a lot of
interesting projects are looking to how
agriculture or even livestock farming
could happen on those small spaces other
approaches for using the space focus on
climate regulation supply and
distribution in the city the city of the
future will need to find solutions to
all sorts of problems
Stowers they include traffic jams and
other traffic problems expensive energy
and problems with electricity supply
which varies a lot in cities across the
world
elf debate in this virtual city of
tomorrow cars actually clean the air and
energy is used efficiently we're trying
to create a city of tomorrow in which
the things that are key to a high
quality of life are always available and
where these things are affordable enough
so that everyone has access to them for
now it's all still a vision of the
future but one day these ideas might
make our cities more livable and also
more sustainable